hello and welcome to this video playing
the test waiking so let's see what the
test waiking can do we've got some dutch
defense and i'm going with the e3 line i
recently saw that there was an an
article or something like that sir way
in chessbase magazine about this line
but have not studied it yet okay this is
an interesting way to play I would like
to play mmm 92 but he's got queen before
it's not very nice I can take with the
bishop play 95 yeah just go for the
better minor piece let's do this ok ok I
can take now if that it's just just
equal now it's just equal i guess but ok
i'm putting I mean I'm controlling if I
for the moment own he allows this trade
interesting
hmm
psycho 92 what are you doing taking
maybe he's got cream before as well that
is a bit irritating this move this one
ok
9f 4-pin intending night h5 that's equal
yeah anyway but Sir or equal ish let's
same but going to know it's not going g5
maybe is going a five-year let's play
this first make sure queen before it's
not happening sorry about my voice got
it slight cold so maybe after that the
longest journey and the night will
finally come to e5 one day might have to
yeah looks a bit awkward
he4s made on f1 unfortunately whatever I
want to do is if possible is trade trade
routes and to get the 935 nie Dage 3g5
f3 this kind of thing
h5 was a surprising move I didn't think
of this idea or
Teague share this night and Sam this
rook takes so let's go here jun to g5
one problem for black is that is king is
really open i can go to h to where the
my king where is quite safe and now is
visibly on a somewhat empty diagonal
it's not doing much
angling for you fro here opening up
against the skin
it was an idea anyway
yeah it looks bad I think I'm in much
I'm going to earn a great shape here
that looks good look at four ed five
seems to win and here also I don't see a
move for him now if you take will be six
minutes the Queen
yeah just rookie 54 is there something
better Ponte eggs
yeah okay if I chick with the rook who
collect resigns he resides soon okay
that's nice I wasn't so sure actually I
mean white is better but I wasn't sure
like this this and and he goes somewhere
on Kiawah d2 and I wasn't so sure how
I'm winning because of this and where
can the engine gives night age three
this is not not particularly easy to
play ok let's go back I think probably
at some point and I was in trouble I
feel like Queen before things like that
could have worked I can engine gives
like a slight edge but nothing special
this ok of course I can take yeah that's
equal but I wanted to try some things
again i can t yeah but i didn't want to
play it in this in such a simple way ya
know the engine gives Queenie 7 as good
kind of super okay okay okay Kim yeah it
comes g5 that's very strong yeah if I
play like this black and take evoke a
sense is it so bad
let's kind of playable shouldn't be so
bad engine is on minus 0.2 so nothing
extraordinary in here i felt i'm ok
before already was possible but this
cannot be bad I miss Knight f3 yet or
source code jam directly going to d5 and
the engine gives this is still ok for
black then it makes sense before it's a
hit a crucial square of course this an
owie form yeah here we get the get the
game position which as I said is not
that yeah yeah I mean why it's better
but it's not not something super
convincing and easy winning awesome ok
thanks for watching